welcome to this video playing feeder
master LUN zone mostly from n mark yeah
that's a cool name take it from the
motion picture midnight run from from
the is it the mid-80s somewhere on that
with some robert de niro and Charles
Grodin but this character is played by
Yaphet Kotto if i'm not mistaken finally
we you get to see it it's a remake
though I think of a French movie which I
never saw or just you did I see it once
I think I did it's very long time ago
okay um i tutor came we we have a mouse
key attack and one of those weird lines
where I played c5 quickly and now I'm
wondering why I did that now I have a
position which is I don't know it feels
a bit shaky but I have firm central
control what I'm thinking about is what
about the movie 5 in this particular
position is this a move that I should do
I don't know I one known I mean if it
looks loose yeah my center but I have
got a big center with possibly d5 or a 5
coming up he has got the Queen on c1 so
night c4 it's not winning in the d6 bond
like it would be with Queen on d1 if he
goes Bishop c4 I play d 5 this should be
fine now in the big big porn center and
he's given me the bishops anyway put
shire of the slave like no it's a bit
opener the King side but
it's not apparent how why should drama
bomb i get some sort of attack on my
king yeah this is a move yeah mm-hmm I
was briefly thinking about it but it
looks it looks weird to open up the g7
bishop so so enormously whoo interesting
i'm still interesting what is good here
I wonder again he five is still
interesting simply because it takes up
so much much space in the center 95
taking as probably good term it's not a
bad line but I don't want to close the
long diagonal this is such a strong
strong feature of my position hmm not
not easy though nitey form
that's very interesting if I go if five
I still like it come on let's do it if
you use night if I'm going to exchange a
playboy this should be really a good
parole he doesn't that's surprising okay
yeah I understand that um he didn't want
to go to the structure that I was
describing but still this looks like i
have a very nice space advantage where
to go i'm not sure where to go with the
Queen actually I like to prepare his 6
in b5 even gaining more space odyssey
want to play before let's discourage
that
okay it's not not so clear how to
proceed i mean it's it's obviously okay
for black with the center but how do i
actually make progress I can also just
now came let's let's shift gears here
you will play before at some point and I
will simply ignore it I will take it if
he does not prepared with a 3 i'm going
to go in to do something on the G file
aha aha going to fianchetto so I should
probably get the Queen away and I have a
good spot
over here I wonder about age five year
now come on let's let's do it I'm a bit
down on time also should them speed up a
little bit at least I actually believe
he should go H form I can play night no
Knight f3 this may be Knight f3 could be
an interesting move intending night h4
okay I know Knight f3 I saw the idea
okay but I can take I have it's not it's
not a disaster 95 I have Queenie seven
you know Knight f3 attacks h4 and
intense 95 but I can take on d3 energy
five is not a big problem okay so I
gained a bit a bit on the clock what now
tween g6 yep maybe
yeah this is the kind of impending down
the hatches approach okay I'm not not
bad I mean okay I'm Queen h5 now I guess
getting into this pin oh now this I
didn't see but what if what if i take it
I mean age five is protected i can just
take it up white resides oh that was
that was a sudden end to this game young
okay I found I had a good position but
it wasn't certainly we know anything or
the computer is very optimistic gives
just black two pawns minus two poor
that's a lot hey okay I mean it's
obviously a good position I mean I have
the center i have two bishops i have the
jackie air but so this is quite a lot i
didn't i didn't expect it to be such a
big big advantage yeah i have multiple
possibilities here to to improve i can
American I can play a form at some point
which must be considered carefully of
course but this is one one idea to open
up the G file you can try it with pieces
like Nigeria centralized with 94 it's on
stage the only weakness on d6 is easily
protected with the rook the computer
gives something like that just to put
something on the board then back yeah
and it gives two points to black this is
in fact a good maneuver maybe even
Bishop to e7 could be an idea just cover
d6 and then shift the heavy pieces over
to the G and H
I I really have my doubts that here the
TM when he played c4 I don't I don't I
don't like that at all it gives gives
away the c-4 square for the night and it
opens up this diagonal and d5 I mean
this wasn't the only move but it was so
tempting to play because 95 is what I
expected and then I take and play you
for and again it's this long diagonal
and I don't have any immediate
structural weakness in this position
okay d6f five but they're not even the
attacked and this is just a fantastic
piece and um yeah and you went here but
I don't think that this is a better
relief because this is so far away from
from the action on on d5 and did just I
mean black black has four pawns
influencing the center well why does
only got those at some plus the bishop
am so it was some really not too well um
executed opening I guess alright thanks
for watching